qu'est ce que ça signifie d'être
républicaine des 30 et 40 tout comme au
début du xxème siècle ont des
républicains c'est bien qu'on n'est pas
mon avis ça ne dit rien d'autre
rien d'autre parce que les antilles
nations et les nationalistes les plus
durs les antisémites les plus durs cd
républicain de riba bleuté monarchiste
guérin était monarchiste enfin ne veut
pas sommet les gens que quand on ne sait
pas qu'il serait lé qui va se rappeler
maintenant drummond et dry et drummond
ou guérin mais quand il fait sans
d'ailleurs on a déjà en 1943 pourquoi un
certain valin qui est un des leaders de
preuves qui lui passe à londres en 43
évidemment est considéré comme un
traître par eux et par la roque
ces gens là ne sont pas passés dans la
récente ils sont pas devenus résistants
ce n'est pas vrai ils ont compris que le
vent tournait que le vent tourne et que
la guerre rennes une issue autre que
celle qui se dessine est un peu plus tôt
et alors évidemment en même temps ces
gens là ce n'était pas il était
nationaliste il ne voulait pas que la
france soit un feu aux deux par
l'allemagne
il voudrait qu'elle ait sa place dans
une europe nouvelle et cette europe
nouvelle maintenant à wil elle n'existe
plus à 43 elle n'existe plus et à
l'arôme voir y compris un françois
mitterrand qui était devenu lui était
devenu résistant qui a risqué sa vie
comme beaucoup d'autres mais c'était
déjà des hommes qui courait au secours
de la victoire n'est pas l'oubli
les résistants véritable ceux qui se
sont lancés dans la résistance en 40 41
42 étaient des héros étaient des héros
ils méritent ils méritent comme
s'incline devant eux mais ceux qui sont
arrivés en 43 44 c'était des
opportunistes je n'ai aucun respect pour
les résistants de 43 44
[Musique]